foreign
so in the last few lectures we have
derived from scratch simple first order
linear differential equations and today
we're going to take a pretty big step
going from first order differential
equations where you only have a single
derivative DX DT to second order
differential equations where you have
second derivatives D squared x DT and
things like that and these systems are
going to come up all the time in physics
because Newton's Second Law f equals m a
is in fact a second order differential
equation okay so I'm just going to start
by a simple example by kind of writing
down a simple example from physics where
we can write down f equals m a and then
we're going to we're going to see how to
solve that second order differential
equation it's good and I think I'm going
to solve it four ways so we'll have you
know four different ways to solve the
second order linear system
so the system I want to look at is
called the harmonic oscillator harmonic
oscillator
and that is just a super fancy term
you've heard harmonic oscillator before
probably it's just a really really fancy
term for anything that oscillates
linearly like if I have a mass on a
spring or if I have a pendulum those are
both examples of harmonic oscillators
these also come up in Optics and quantum
mechanics all over the place you know
electromagnetism so the example I want
to draw
is where you basically have I'm going to
draw this horizontally because I don't
want to consider gravity just imagine
that I have a mass
a mass
m
attached to a spring with a spring
constant K okay so this is a spring
and we're going to assume that it has a
rest position so there's basically a
rest position for this spring k
um where basically
um you know there's some X rest
that's this length and anything in
addition so the center of mass of this
uh of this Mass from that rest position
is going to be called my variable X so
the state of the system that we're going
to model X is a function of T is
basically the position of this Mass away
from its rest position so I'm going to
do things like I'm going to pull this
Mass away from its equilibrium and let
it go and you're going to of course in
your mind see this thing oscillating X
of T is going to give me Sines and
cosines probably that's what we're going
to model
and we're going to start with Newton's
Second Law like I said we're going to
start with Newtons
was it a brand new very nice pen
Newton's
second law of motion uh which you all
are familiar with as f equals m a force
equals mass times acceleration and of
course acceleration in this case is the
second time derivative of position so
velocity let's just say you know V
equals velocity
equals DX DT
a equals acceleration
equals DV DT
which equals D Squared X
DT squared sorry if that's a little
small but this is you know what we're
all familiar with from basic basic
physics is that you know X
is my position
of this Mass away from equilibrium V is
the velocity a is acceleration uh so the
velocity is the first derivative of my
position in time the acceleration is my
second derivative of my position in time
and this is where that second order is
going to come from is now we're going to
have a second derivative in X we're
going to have a differential equation in
terms of the second derivative in fact
this Newton's second law
so
um how do we derive this we say you know
X is the displacement from its rest
position and the force on this mass is
proportional to K times x so this is
just again this is um I think this is a
hooke's law or something like that where
you know the more I pull this Mass away
from its equilibrium the larger X is the
larger the restorative Force for that
spring so the force from the spring the
spring
force is I believe going to be minus
K times x
so if I pull X in the positive direction
here I'm going to have a restoring Force
trying to pull it back you know in the
negative X Direction and it's going to
be proportional to X
okay so this is actually really really
easy
um I think the first thing I'm going to
do is you know uh we're going to start
by assuming
um you know Mass equals one and k equals
one we'll relax that a little bit later
but we're just you know to make my life
easier I'm just going to assume that the
mass is one and the spring constants one
and so what we get when we write down
Newton's second law
is that DDT of
um how to underwrite this so you know
you can write this as a equals F over M
that's also fine and N is one because I
said my Mass is equal to one so my
acceleration is D Squared X
DT squared that's a
and that equals my Force divided by one
and my force is minus
K is one my constant is one I made
everything one so it's just minus
X that's my differential equation this
is literally Newton's Second Law f
equals m times a okay Force equals mass
times acceleration mass is one my spring
constant's one so I get X double dot
equals minus X and yeah if I want to
write this in a little bit simpler
notation I'll just say x double dot
equals minus X
this is my simplest second order linear
differential equation this comes up all
the time in physics pretty much
any system that oscillates any system
that is periodic and linear like a
pendulum with a small angle or this Mass
on a spring
um you know lots of phenomena in Optics
and electromagnetism and quantum
mechanics are also oscillatory and
linear are going to be governed by this
second order linear differential
equation that we call the harmonic
oscillator equation okay so we derived
it from first principles f equals m a is
generally speaking going to give us
second order systems because a is the
second derivative of my position or my
state it's got okay
so now we're going to solve this
differential equation four ways and I'm
going to build up a bunch of lectures on
you know kind of how to understand these
second order systems
um I kind of uh I like to start with the
easiest approach so so method one
method one
and this is second order systems
literally X double dot equals minus X in
case I erase this so method one is is
pretty simple and I actually find this
to be a pretty useful approach in
differential equations this is what
people have done for for centuries is
you guess what the solution is and you
plug it in and you see if it works it's
like actually very physical this is what
we call the physics solution this is
what I call the physics solution method
one is guess okay so guess
and what's a pretty good guess for the
function X of T okay so we know that if
I pull this Mass I guess it's over here
but imagine you know I'm pulling this
mass and I let it go and it starts
oscillating what is a function that
oscillates in time
well our basic functions of oscillating
time are cosines and Sines okay and at T
equals zero sine of T is zero
so if I have a non-zero initial
condition I'm probably going to get
something that looks a lot like a cosine
function okay because it's going to
oscillate and it starts off not at zero
so I'm going to assume that my uh my
system X at T the position of this thing
would I you know at time zero and it's
going to have some initial condition
let's say
um X
at time zero equals x naught okay it's
some non-zero initial condition and
maybe I'll say uh my derivative x dot at
time 0 equals V naught let's say that
that equals zero so I start this thing
at an initial position but with no
velocity and then I let it go that's
what this says is that the initial
condition is X naught and my initial
velocity is zero
then our very reasonable guess would be
Sines and cosines for this function X of
T and specifically I'm going to guess
that it is a cosine function because at
t 0
cosine is not zero and at t 0 the
derivative of cosine is zero so this
matches my initial position zero
velocity
and I'll need to multiply this by X zero
okay so at time 0 if I plug in 0 for
time x naught equals my initial
condition so this is a very reasonable
guess okay and this is what we do a lot
in in physics and in math and applied
math is you look at your system and you
say to yourself well okay this is
growing exponentially or it's decaying
or it's oscillating and you kind of get
some intuition about what you think that
solution is going to look like
so of course x dot of T is going to
equal minus sine of t x naught and then
X double dot of T is again going to be
minus
cosine of t
X naught and you can verify you know
really simply almost in your head that
yes in fact X double dot is minus
X of T so these functions satisfy this
differential equation relationship that
has to be true at all times to satisfy
Newton's Second Law right Newton's
second law is essentially conservation
of momentum uh and and this is true
always it's true every you know for
every system that I draw a big enough
box around this is going to be true
and you can verify just by inspection
that if I choose this function cosine of
T then its second derivative is minus
cosine of T and it satisfies this
relationship so kind of you know in this
case for these linear simple systems we
can kind of guess and we usually get the
right answer okay good
um and I'll just write down that uh you
know for General
for General mass and K you're going to
get specifically that now you know X of
T equals I think
cosine oh sorry this is so squeaky let's
see if I can switch to this one you're
going to get a cosine of root K Over m
T times x naught
where essentially this K Over M square
root is like the natural frequency so
you're basically going to have like uh
Omega
equals root K Over m is going to be the
natural frequency of that oscillating
Mass uh on a spring okay and you can
derive this one from scratch so what you
would do is you would not set M and K
equal to one and you would keep this as
minus KX and you would keep this as M
times x double dot and then you divide
both sides and you get X double dot
equals minus K Over m x and you would
find in fact that this is the solution
so that's a homework for you is to again
you know verify that if I take the
second derivative of this that equals
minus this okay
okay I'm going to erase this and then
we're going to try method two
okay
so there's a lot of ways to skin this
cat don't skin cats and there's a lot of
ways to solve this problem the second
method we're going to use is the Taylor
series
and again I don't really recommend you
know most of the time solving
differential equations with Taylor
series expansions unless you have to but
I like to show this method because if
all else fails you can always just you
know expand X of T in powers of T and
solve for the coefficients and it
actually is pretty useful at this stage
just to build intuition for what's
happening so that's what we're going to
do and this is just like we did in the
last few lectures so I'm going to write
down
where do I want to do this I probably
don't want to like chop my head off so
let's say I start here and I'm just
going to say you know X of T equals some
constant C naught plus C1 t plus C2 t
squared plus C3 T cubed and let's say I
need to go up to T to the fourth
probably plus C4 t to the fourth plus
dot dot this goes on forever it's a
Taylor series expansion or a power
series expansion so this is only you
know true if I keep all of the terms in
t
and so I'm just going to compute both of
its derivatives
so x dot of T is equal to now C1
plus let's see I can make this orange
plus uh 2 c 2 t
plus 3 c 3 t squared plus 4 C 4 T cubed
plus dot dot dot
um
maybe I'll write plus five
I'll try to keep all of the terms
because I'm going to be setting them
equal to each other so I'll keep you
know plus 5 C 5 t to the fourth plus dot
dot dot
and then the second derivative of x dot
X double dot of T is going to now again
I'm just taking the derivative of x dot
at my velocity and this is going to
equal
2c2
plus 3 times 2 c 3 t
plus four times three remember the power
rule 4 times 3
C 4 t squared
plus 5 times 4 C 5 T cubed plus
and if I had a third order equation with
an x triple dot I'd have to compute x
triple dot here and I would get you know
more hairy terms nothing nothing super
complicated and now I'm literally just
like we've always done going to set X
double dot equal to minus X and we're
going to make sure that the constants at
each power of t equal each other because
this has to be true for all time which
means it has to be that the the
constants equal each other the
coefficients of the T to the one power
equal each other the coefficients of the
t squared terms they have to be equal
and opposite actually they have to equal
the opposite of each other and so on and
so forth so that's going to give me a
recursion relationship so that I can
write down what is C2 in terms of C
naught what is C3 in terms of C1 and so
on and so forth
um and I think I'm going to use the fact
again
because exit time 0 is X naught and if I
plug in t 0 all of this goes to zero
except for C naught so I probably have
the relationship that
um
C naught
equals
X naught
and similarly if I take my first
derivative x dot at time 0 all of these
terms in Orange go to zero and I'm only
left with C1 and so C1 is equal to my
initial velocity
which we set equal to zero okay so let's
say this is equal to zero
initial velocity this will actually be
more interesting this way um I hope I
don't butcher my notes but let's say I
actually do start with an initial
velocity so I don't just pull this mass
and Let It Go with no velocity I pull
this Mass back and I kind of push it a
little at some velocity I give it some
little initial velocity so now it has an
initial position and an initial velocity
so in that case again
x dot at 0 c 1 has to be my initial
velocity
C1 has to equal
V naught and that's enough information
now to uniquely determine C2 and C3 and
C4 and C5 by equating all of these uh
coefficients in a recursion relation so
let's just do it so again remember we're
writing uh X double dot equals minus X
so that means
um
I have two
I have two c two
equals minus C naught equals minus C
naught
which implies
that C2
equals minus one half X naught
that's pretty easy 2c2 equals minus X
naught so C2 equals minus one half X
naught
similarly I get my C3 this term has to
equal minus this term
so I get
um
3 times 2
C3
equals minus C1
and again C1 is V naught
and so this equals
C3 equals
minus 1 over 3 times 2 which I'm going
to write as 3 factorial
times V naught
and two factorial is equal to two Okay
so I've already computed my C3 and my C2
coefficient so let's see what C4 and C5
are and I think at that point we'll be
able to stop and we'll be able to write
down the solution uh maybe I'll switch
colors here just to keep it a little
neater
so my C4 coefficient is on my t squared
here so I have 4 times 3 C4
equals
minus
C2 that equals minus C2 because it's
this equation equals minus C2
which implies
that C4
equals
minus C2 divided by 4 divided by 3.
n minus C2 is
1 over 2 factorial
times x naught
and so
minus C2 divided by 4 divided by 3 is 1
over 2 times 3 times 4.
which is a 4 factorial okay so
um
if that was a little fast just pause and
convince yourself that that's true
I literally take this expression for C2
I minus it and I divide by 3 and I
divide by 4 and that gives me C4 equals
one over four factorial X naught
similarly for the C5 term here I have 5
times 4 C 5 equals minus C3
again that's the T cubed terms have to
be equal
and again that means I'm going to get
something that looks like minus
so C5
is minus C3
divided by 4 divided by 5. so that's
minus 1 over 5 factorial times V naught
and you can go you know on and on and on
and on forever okay so it's pretty clear
what the pattern here is all of the even
terms
are multiplied by X naughts all of the
odd terms are multiplied by V naughts
and again if you are pretty familiar
with exponential functions and Sines and
cosines in their power series you'll
recognize pretty quickly that these are
starting to look like cosines and sine
components but let's put those all
together for X of T and see what we get
okay and maybe I'll do it in um
here so I have a
uh yeah I'll do this in two steps just
because I don't want to
um
I don't want to confuse anyone
so what I'm going to do the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm literally just
going to write X of T
um
and plug in all of those coefficients
here and then I'm going to group all of
my X knots and my v-nots so X of t
equals
X naught
plus v naught t
C2 is minus
1 over 2 factorial
X naught times t squared
C3 is
I feel like I'm missing a minus sign
yeah this is supposed to be minus
right this is a C3 equals minus C1 so
there's a minus there and C5 is minus C3
so this is a plus sign okay thank you
I'm sure many of you caught that
um so sorry my um I already have my C2
now my C3 term
is minus
one over three factorial V naught T
cubed and I'm going to have uh plus one
over four factorial X naught again t to
the fourth plus one over five factorial
V naught
t to the fifth minus dot dot dot okay
this is literally I'm just taking this
expression here and I'm plugging in what
we got from our recursion relationship
from our recurrence relationship for all
of these constants okay in terms of X
naught and V naught and now I can take
all of the terms
that are only functions of X dots
and I can take all of my terms that are
only functions of
V naught and I can write those down and
I can say that X of T equals
maybe I'll write this in yellow I get
X naught times uh 1 minus
t squared over 2 factorial
plus t to the fourth over 4 factorial
you know minus I'm sure it's going to be
2 to the 6 over 6 factorial plus dot dot
dots okay that's all of my terms that
are X naughts
and then I'm also going to get plus v
naught
times all of these these odd powers in t
okay so I'm going to get V naught times
T minus 1 over 3 factorial T cubed plus
1 over 5 factorial t to the fifth dot
dot dot dot forever and ever and ever
and lo and behold this is the Taylor
series for cosine and this is the Taylor
series for sine and so what we find is
that X of t
equals
the yellow for my cosine this is cosine
of T times x naught times my initial
position
Plus
sine of T times my initial velocity and
that is the solution to this
differential equation now for a generic
initial position and initial velocity so
remember when I guessed I had to use the
simple case where there was Zero initial
velocity or else I might have messed up
my guess when you do the Taylor series
you can actually have your initial
position and initial velocity and it
just kind of pops out that you get
um
cosine times the initial position plus
sine times the initial velocity so these
are kind of out of phase so if I start
with you know some initial position and
an initial velocity this is my generic
solution good okay
um that was method two and this is again
not recommended to use this every day
when you're solving differential
equations but really important to know
that almost every solution of every
differential equation you'll ever see
you could solve it using these kind of
first principles Taylor series Power
series expansions good okay method three
I'm going to erase this and we're going
to solve method three
okay we are solving this second order
differential equation which we derived
from Newton's Second Law f equals m a
for the position of this Mass on a
spring so X is the position uh X double
dot is its acceleration and the force of
the spring is minus X so this is the
differential equation we've already
solved this two ways now we're going to
solve it a third way so the first time
we just guessed cosine Solutions because
you know that seemed reasonable given
that it's oscillating it's a you know
springy Mass the second solution was
Taylor series we actually wrote out in a
Taylor series expansion for X of T the
third method we're going to guess again
we're gonna guess
again
but instead of guessing that our
solution X of T is some cosine solution
we're going to guess something a little
different so
remember
what function when we take its
derivatives
are up until a constant looks like
itself so in first order systems x dot
equals Lambda X we saw that the
exponential function was the very
natural solution because then if I take
the derivative of e to the Lambda you
know T I get something that up to a
constant is also e to the Lambda T just
remember you know I'll write this out
what function
what function
when taking multiple derivatives
when taking
multiple
derivatives
equals itself up to a constant is
similar to itself
is similar similar to itself to itself
has a lot of self awareness to itself
up to a constant
and so of course up to a constant
we know that the answer is the
exponential function I can take the
derivative of e to the T as many times
as I want and I get exactly e to the T
back
so
um you know X of T equals e to the
Lambda T is a pretty good guess for the
solution of differential equations
because if I take the second derivative
let's write this down x dot is going to
be Lambda e to the Lambda T and X double
dot is going to be Lambda squared
e to the Lambda T so I always get
something that looks just like itself
and so I can kind of again equate these
two equal and opposite to each other I
can plug these two into this equation
and I get
that Lambda squared e to the Lambda T
better equal minus
e to the Lambda T that's just X double
dot equals minus X
and of course this has to be true for
all times because Newton's Second Law
doesn't ever take any breaks it never
goes to sleep it never has sick days
it's true for all time that we're aware
of and so this is true for all of these
e to the Lambda T's which means that
Lambda squared has to equal minus one
that's the only way that this can be
true
so Lambda squared equals minus one
which means I'll switch colors here that
means that Lambda equals the square root
of -1 which is plus or minus I so Lambda
could equal plus I or minus I
and this is really interesting now what
we have is that our solution X of T is
going to be written in terms of e to the
plus I T's and e to the minus I T's very
very interesting
differential equation meaning that the
derivative
bye
okay that was not a drill apparently
those were fire alarms
okay
because this differential equation is
linear
meaning that the derivatives are
linearly proportional to the state X
that means that linear superposition
holds so if I have two solutions to the
system then if I add those Solutions up
that's also a solution to the system and
so what that means is that the candidate
for X of T is now X of T it could be e
to the
plus I T or it could also be e to the
minus i t if I took either of those
Solutions and I took the second
derivative
uh literally you know the second
derivative of e to the i t is minus E to
the i t or I squared e to the i t is a
solution by differential equation and so
is this
so the sum of these two is also a
solution of my differential equation so
we're going to say that this is a
constant one plus constant two
and now we get to determine the
coefficients C1 and C2 based on our
initial conditions and specifically you
know e to the i t is going to have a
real part and an imaginary part and so
I'm going to also choose C1 and C2 so
that it basically is only a real valued
function because of course you know if I
pull this mass and Let It Go
I can't get an imaginary position or an
imaginary velocity I can't get a complex
valued position or velocity and so these
coefficients have to perfectly add up so
that only the real part of these
functions remains okay that's kind of
interesting that you know I now have
these complex lambdas but of course my
position of velocity are still going to
be real
so let's do this and so now I know that
e to the i t is cosine t plus I sine of
T and so I can write this as you know I
can basically write down the real part
and the imaginary part I'm going to get
something like
C1 plus C2
times cosine of t
plus I
times C1 minus C2
times sine of T and this is just using
Euler's formula literally that you know
e to the i t equals cosine of t plus I
sine
of T So similarly e to the minus i t
equals cosine
of minus t but cosine's even so that's
also cosine of t plus I sine to minus t
that's odd so it's minus I sine
of T and you can plug these in here and
get this expression
essentially give me the um
initial conditions that I'm looking for
okay and let's see uh
is there something
technically these constants could be
complex valued or real valued
um and so I think what I'm going to find
is
yeah okay let's just let's just work it
out I don't know what the answer is
we're going to try it so uh we have some
initial condition is that you know X at
times zero uh is going to be just you
know cosine of zero is one sine of zero
zero so that equals C1 plus C2
and similarly if I take the derivative
of this you know x dot
at zero the derivative of cosine is
minus sine and sine of zero zero so this
term will be zero and this will be
cosine of T cosine of zero will be one
so x dot at 0 is going to equal
I times C1 minus C2
and so what that means is that C1 plus
C2 has to equal my initial position and
I times C1 minus C2 has to equal my
initial velocity and probably I could
figure out
um using you know complex analysis that
these coefficients have a real and an
imaginary part and I could you know
figure out exactly how to make these add
up to equal a you know real X naught and
their difference times I would equal a
real V naught
I'm just going to punt a little and say
let's let's imagine that V naught equals
zero so I just start this thing with an
initial position and Let It Go
then that means that uh C1 has to equal
C2 okay for this to equal zero and that
means that uh
C1 equals C2 so C1 equals C2 equals x
naught over two
you could definitely solve this for a
non-zero velocity I just don't want to
do it on the spot right now that might
be a good homework problem is kind of
work out the complex analysis if this is
a non-zero V naught but for initial
velocity equal to zero these constants
have to equal each other and they both
equal x naught over over two and so that
literally means that the solution again
is equal to
X naught
cosine T good okay so that again is a
third way of confirming our intuition
that this thing is going to be built up
of Sines and cosines and that these
constants are going to be used to get my
initial condition and initial velocity
okay I'll erase this and show up the
fourth uh method and we'll just briefly
talk through that
okay
method I'm just going to write this down
I'm actually not going to solve it using
this method but this is going to be the
basis of a lot of the future lectures
is Method four is what we're going to do
is we're going to introduce a new
variable where this is called suspending
the variables so suspend
variables
essentially what that means is that we
introduce a new variable V
introduce a new variable
V equals DX DT
and I'm going to turn the second order
linear differential equation into a
system of first order differential
equations so I'm going to say x dot
equals V and now V Dot equals minus X
and this allows me to write this as a
matrix system of differential equations
so now I can have a vector X and V
and DDT of this vector
is going to be a matrix
times that state X and V so D DT of X is
V so that's 0 1 that gives me x dot
equals v d DT of V is minus X so I put a
minus 1 here and 0 there that is that
equation and now I went from a second
order system meaning I have second
derivatives because Newton's second law
has second derivatives now I have a
system of two first order systems these
are only first derivatives so this is a
system
kind of a matrix system of
first order
Odes
and you can always do this if you have a
second order system you can get as a
system of two coupled first order
equations they're coupled because x dot
depends on V and V Dot depends on on X
if I have a third derivative in x triple
dot equals something I could write this
as a system of three variables and so on
and so forth so I'll show you all of
this in the next lecture but what's
really neat here is that this Vector now
is the state of my system that uniquely
defines my my system the position and
the velocity
and now I have you know an initial
condition that again is a vector
um you know X naught V naught
and I'm going to show you in in future
lectures when you write this system uh
DDT of let's call it X and V equals this
big a matrix this is a two by two Matrix
now
times x and V and I'm going to Define
this state X and V we're going to call
this like the Bold
this under bar means it's a vector State
okay that means this the state with two
components we're going to see that x dot
equals Matrix a times x has a solution
which is X of T equals The Matrix
exponential e to the a t times my Vector
of initial conditions X at time zero so
I'm going to show you all of this in the
future lectures this is how we solve
really big systems of equations or
really high order systems is by writing
them in this Matrix system of equations
way and teaser those lambdas that I
showed you those lambdas that equal plus
and minus I those are the eigenvalues
the eigenvalues of this a matrix okay so
the eigenvalues of this a matrix when
you
um when you suspend variables and write
this as a system of first order
equations the eigenvalues of that a
matrix are the lambdas the kind of e to
the land is that you would use to solve
the system so that's going to be a deep
connection that's how we're actually
going to derive the eigenvalue and
eigenvector equation is to solve these
equations and that's all coming up soon
thank you
foreign